you think you know a lot about space
well then you should know true or false
Jupiter is the largest planet in our
solar system
well that's true Jupiter is the largest
planet in our solar system it's big
enough to fit one thousand Earths inside
of it okay true or false a day on Venus
is longer than a year on Earth
oh that's false today on Venus is long
but it's only 5 800 hours that's the
equivalent of 243 Earth days now true or
false the first animal to go into space
was a dog
oh that's false again the first animals
sent into space were bugs fruit flies
made the trip in 1947 and returned to
Earth alive true or false Mars has one
Moon
oh that's false too Mars has two moons
how'd you do let us know in the comments
below